[Music]
well Alison congratulations on getting
married recently
how's newlywed life and please tell me
dave has seen the first episode of glow
oh he definitely has he's glows biggest
fan and everything's great I think it's
a great time in my life not you know in
our lives I feel like collectively not
necessarily globally but being married
to me it's similar to the experience
working on this show in that it's been a
very empowering year and a very sort of
settled feeling year uh I don't know why
those two things have kind of gone
hand-in-hand for me but they have
wrestling and marriage you're both just
like yeah I can take on anything are you
just like texting him selfies of these
crazy alphas music okay definitely oh
yeah I like to send in videos of moves
which progressively got cooler I feel
like the day one of wrestling training
were just doing like a hog Moo
dimensionally somersaults and he was
like cool but then as I showed him moves
later he was genuinely excited and
impressed this is about justice
you